j'accueille maintenant
[Musique]
c
yann moix
yann moix bonsoir vous oubliez votre
troisième livre le premier c'était
jubilation vers le ciel le deuxième
c'était les cimetières sont des champs
de fleurs et le troisième c'est alice à
corto il est sorti il ya quelques mois
ils étaient bien accueillis vous savez
comment on fait yann moix alice accord
très bien alors le pitch le fait vous le
faites
allez j'y viens alors donc le narrateur
je fais court mais c'est un pitch le
narrateur sort d'une école de commerce
il est embauché à disneyland après un
concours de recrutement soit disant basé
sur la culture générale et il devient
donald le mec il devient donald à
disneyland avec le truc et tout lui qui
a lu proust eagle brecht entre tous est
un peu dure pour lui se retrouve donald
et fait une tentative de suicide et à ce
moment là il le seul recours qui lui
apparaît ça ne vous surprendra pas jean
marie bigard c'est l'amour il décide d
mais une jeune fille une jeune beurette
qu'ils voient comme ça et qu'il qu'ils
traquent sans jamais osé l'aborder
ils l'attrapent jusque dans son hlm il
s'installe dans son appartement quand
elle déménage et vous dit yann moix
derrière le masque hilare de donald duck
pleurer un petit c les batteurs amoureux
d'une beurette en couple et voilà tout
est dit c'est la trame du livre quant à
la trame du livre est la seule issue
pour assouvir sa passion c'est le crime
et le canard tranche la carotide d'alice
à corto elle m'avait refusé des instants
elle m'accorderai l'éternité voilà
c'est bien le livre de yann moix et
croustade marne la vallée voilà oui non
c'est de montrer effectivement que il ya
des métiers bizarre sur la terre comme
par exemple déguisée des êtres humains
en animaux et les mettre dans des parcs
à thèmes et c'est quand même assez
absurde quoi c'est la déshumanisation et
total à dire qu'en plus il faut que les
mecs se taisent
c'est des mecs qui viennent des pays de
l'est en général qui ont fait la manche
dans le métro pendant des années et là
ils se sont tous retrouvés pour faire
donald dingo mickey alors c'est
fascinant parce qu'il ya des séances de
dédicaces plutôt dédicacera je sais pas
quoi une feuille de papier de 17 heures
à 18 heures au palais enchanté cvc aussi
conques donner des farines animales à
des animaux végétaux rien exactement
il ya un côté fascinant disney c'est
viens là et amuse-toi il ya un côté
obligatoire et totalitaire de
divertissement qui est extrêmement
angoissant j'ai appelé ça moi une fois
le goulag du bonheur parfaitement voilà
c'est le goulag du bonheur parce qu'il
est petit off qui nous a rejoint boston
[Applaudissements]
josh smith avec vous la semaine
prochaine mais vient s'asseoir dieu avec
nous que tu fais as tu t'en vas à la
maison ah c'était un coucou bon bah à
samedi prochain titoff ciao bella ciao
korbosly des mégacités qui ont voulu
transgresser ils ont bien eu raison
un peu la règle de disney ils ont foutu
balle ou de dully de la jungle pas du
livre de la jungle à la flotte et
lamballe où s'est fait virer parce que
les gestes qui faisait pour de bon au
secours il n'était pas réglementaire
n'est pas censé faire ces gestes là
ouais c'est extraordinaire et pensez
aussi que ça rejoint mes pizzas et c'est
très cruel sont les ans et la mairie
c'est ainsi que depuis 1955 que ces
parcs à thème existe il ya un plus tôt
il ya toujours un plutôt de rechange les
mecs qui sont à l'intérieur ils
vieillissent et meurent mais les plus
tôt ils sont toujours là et que ce soit
à tokyo à paris même geste
mais les gestes sont aussi bons
gagner c'est le sait le mc-21 toujours
d'arriver plus tôt donc chaque jour une
échelle sans moi c'est bien ce que
valent les gestes sont mondialisés mais
comme tout ce qui se passe sur le
effectivement sur la bouffe comme mcdo
le big mac
c'est au mexique machin tout c'est
exactement le même et puis ça va le
livre a été très bien accueillis du
savoir ça se passe bien je passe vers
pour vous un bon l'idée de lancement du
livre c'était voilà alors il est marqué
dans le journal appelle moi il s'appelle
moix appelle moi avec son numéro de
portable
vous avez eu 394 appel en trois jours
qui nous a appelés que des mecs
pratiquement que ça c'est le chant c'est
dégueulasse il s'est fait ça uniquement
bon alors ça c'est alors qu'est ce qui
et quels étaient leurs exigences c'était
beaucoup de lecteurs de têtu
par exemple et puis les journalistes
très curieux et puis la seule gonzesse
qui m'a appelé quand d'irkut j'ai envie
de toi immédiatement c'était trois mecs
du figaro qui m'ont fait une blague a
toujours autant de mal pour rattraper
parce que j'avais une émission tu
échoues est nette et 10 mm avec la
notoriété j'arrive pas à traverser
j'ai un vice de forme qui fait que même
si on met dans la peau de mick jagger
pendant trois jours a fait trois jours
de râteaux séjour selon moi il ya un
truc
essayez mickey ouais non mais c'est
marrant parce que quand j'étais au lycée
etc
les rondes idée de certaines nana elle
c'est une [ __ ] à la couche avec tout
le monde moi quand j'arrive et j'étais
le mec sûr que je dors soit salon un peu
trop soit un sourcil qui n'allait pas
soit une manger les initiales avec
le problème jean marie lebon problème
c'est que ma vie je n'ai rencontré du
coup selon la définition que des [ __ ]
non alors sérieusement vous pensiez que
c'était un peu négatif ce coup du
portable parce que honnêtement le
cerveau et non mais c'est un peu détruit
le côté littéraire du livre cette promo
avec le numéro de portable dans le
journal on peut y perdre et les crises
et de la bonne littérature pas
véritablement parce que je vais pas
jouer le plan écrivain interactifs etc
mais il faut bien savoir que
contrairement aux acteurs ou chanteurs
etc
les écrans on n'a jamais de contact avec
notre public en asie mais je sais que
j'en fait des signatures chez o m oui
enfin les signatures il ya 3500
personnes aux côtés de christine deviers
joncour lui dire madame j'adore ce que
vous faites alors sais pas s'ils parlent
des fellations ou des ou du contenu du
livre et dior moi j'ai deux personnes
qui viennent en me disant à quelle heure
ils arrivent frédéric beigbeder c'est un
peu comme beigbeder beigbeder le
lancement était tellement réussie que
finalement ça un peu nui à la qualité au
côté littéraire du lycée un peu passé
comme comme un pamphlet contre la pub
alors que quand même c'est un livre qui
est super bien écrit c'est très bien
parce que moi je suis à 100% du côté de
frédéric c'est qu'il y en a marre du
côté littéraire d'accord moi j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] du côté littéraire on est
là pour pour être le même quels que
soient les circonstances et le téléphone
des émissions de télé sur le internet
si au cinéma machin enfin je veux dire
c'est un tout et le tout à fait pas
jouer à l'écrivain ce que vous dites pas
du tout je veux pas faire du livre
littéraire et c'est dans mes livres je
parle de donald de casimir de l'île aux
enfants de jersey
chaque enfant c'est tous les jours le
battant c'est le pays joyeux des grands
gérants dimanche que j'en dis mais c'est
un paradis à 16h15
brian oblivion chanté par par michel
sardou dans les spectacles de la base''
visite extraordinaire et ordinaire parce
que c'est une chanson qui est écrit par
mireille way que leur gueule et les
chantiers parole et ces femmes qui
chantent aussi la voix de colargol
souvenir est un faible à ses murs et
c'est moi qui suis colargol ce qu'ils
chantent enfance en deviennent en mi
bémol en gilets aux faux col bleu roi
des oiseaux vous savez mes amis
un beau sifflé pour faire future bombe à
bord mais ça c'est un grand clown
moustache c'est chanter une chanson gaza
renault avec gainsbourg chanté des
chansons des chansons en grenot avec la
voix de jacques brel
jacques brel aurait très bien pu le
chanter laisse béton et que tu regardes
ça tout d'un coup marc au début m jeudi
mais [ __ ] jacques vrai alors vraiment
pu s'intéresse baffie moi j'ai une
version de chapi chapo par lou reed
c'est un bootleg un collector
il ya une ligne de basse fort 17 et
sélectionne par l'uci non jour là j'ai
alors dit moi je peux pas jouer donc
plus de femmes n'ont pas plus de femmes
n'ont même plus de râteaux ouais parce
que vous dit en fait en parlant du sais
que j'ai tout devient énorme et et le
sexe ne fait pas exception
mais non il ya un truc qui est très
drôle c'est que je suis allé voir sur un
site de prostituées récemment rien c'est
quadrillé là je la fis son nom son âge
son numéro de portable
les spécialités les tarifs les horaires
et un truc fabuleux la tournée je
voulais me suivre et cetera jeu c'est
fabuleux
alors vous avez des problèmes quand même
vous êtes à votre premier livre qui
s'appelait jubilation vers le ciel vous
écrivez les premiers jours hélène me
refuse à son derrière son popotin ventru
moulés dans la braise et un peu plus
loin elle avait cru devoir il sait très
bien avec lui devoir exclure ceux
d'hommes de sa bible intime c'est plutôt
bien écrit mais super u de la
littérature
ah bah elle avait cru devoir exclure ce
date de sa bible à savoir beaucoup à
définir quand même l'avouer
et alors ça vous a coûté le prix du
premier roman au salon du livre de
bordeaux pouvait se dire que le recteur
de l'académie à un tracteur des voix la
musique je parle de rectum effectivement
et il a refusé de distribuer mon livre
au lycée est éteint alors grasset a donc
mais ça ça reste dans les annales des
éditions grasset points
ok on qui ont envoyé le livre
gratuitement les amours comme ça le
recteur l'aï dit au 1010 j'avais alors
vous savez parc de wesserling
oui oui puisqu'on j'ai envie d'aider ma
philosophie ovidie et anarcho punk et
philosophe
vous étiez narco paris dira le contraire
je crois que son histoire et c'est le
fondement de la métaphysique des moeurs
non non alors quand elle a un autre qui
est contre la fidélité alors lui il dit
moi que sidy l'homme descend du singe et
le bonobo n'a jamais été fidèle je suis
plutôt pour la fidélité ma théorie s'il
faut être fidèle à toutes ses maîtresses
à dacca fidèles aventure voilà alors
vous avez des envies de cinéma vous
aussi regarder chainel a fini par faire
son film est donc vous vous préparez un
film s'appelle podium 1 c'est ça c'est
ça
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui se prend
pour claude françois oui c'est un film
sur l'univers des saisies alors en ce
moment je suis en train de rencontrer
tous les saisies les seconds rôles il
est saisi de cloclo et ses lauriers les
moments fantastiques ou un des sosies
officiels de claude françois dénigre un
de ses collègues en dix ans laisse
tomber aucune personnalité vous avez
déjà fait un court métrage s'appelle
grand oral
c'est quoi le pitch le pitch est une
société dans laquelle tout est sujet à
examen ultra théorique avec la un
candidat arrive
ayant lui pour qu on lui pose des
questions ultra théorique sur la
fellation la sodomie etc et ensuite il
ya les épreuves pratiques et il ya un
jury extrêmement difficile délicat et
extrêmement pointue et ces jeux
pourraient réexaminer la technique de
d'un nom du doigt dans le cul s'il vous
plaît il ya également ce n'est pas au
programme cette année donc c'est un truc
c'est énorme et voilà c'est énorme et
c'est lena du de la vie intime si vous
voulez
on bouge pas pendant le jingle pop
réponse de thierry ardisson bien alors
le portrait chinois ces sites étaient
une fleur je serai mieux autistes
lentilles portrait chinois celle inverse
si vous étiez un défaut je serai la plus
grande qualité de mon pire ennemi
ouais c'est pas mal ça si vous étiez une
rupture je ne peux pas être une rupture
j'ai trop vécu j'ai pas envie d'en
devenir une une injure j'étais une
injure je serai fille de [ __ ] parce que
je suis pour la parité
une malade et si j'étais une maladie je
crois que serait la maladie d'alzheimer
parce que je ne pourrais pas me souvenir
que j'ai la maladie d'alzheimer
un accident de concorde comme ça je
ferai la une de tous les journaux dans
le monde entier pendant un mois une
perversion une perversion ça c'est
difficile je crois que je serai la
zoophilie parce que j'ai jamais
rencontré une tortue d'eau ou un cochon
d'inde me refuser à 69 une guerre une
guerre bat une guerre lubrique c'est à
dire une guerre de position un vice si
j'étais un vice je serai un vice qui
englobe tous les autres vices et le sexe
parce que c'est en même temps un jeu de
hasard est une drogue
une trahison j'étais une trahison très
je suis déjà une imposture jeu peut en
plus être une trahison une arme une arme
si j'étais une arme attendez laissez moi
un peu et une arme
si j'étais une arme je crois que je
serai la culture parce que quand
j'entends le mot revolver je sens ma
culture très bien un supplice le
supplice de la baignoire parce que j'ai
envie de mourir proprement une cicatrice
une cicatrice
le nombril du monde un poison et un
poison
alors là un poison qui coulerait dans
les veines de george w.bush un [ __ ] tu
t'es un [ __ ] serait un gros [ __ ]
comme ça je pourrais sortir une grosse
[ __ ] et si vous étiez une [ __ ] jeté
une [ __ ] sur une cape une fille
capable de coucher avec elle moix ouais
un impôt un impôt sur le sex-appeal
comme ça je serai exonéré une panne bas
une panne d'inspiration qui frapperait
tous les écrivains qui écrivent plus
vite que moi un dictateur hitler il a
écrit des best-sellers avait investi
l'air
moi j'ai pas réussi une infirmité une
infirmité
michel petrucciani parce que j'adore le
jazz and haas à sa guise de bord parce
qu'il a assassiné guy debord un microbe
ah non ça me rendrait malade d'être un
microbe une plaie si j'étais une plaie
je serai ouvertes toute la nuit
un fléau le sida parce que je suis très
people un terroriste je serai un
terroriste écoutez je préfère sauter des
bombes que les faire sauter pas mal une
torture une torture je serai l'avenir
parce que l'avenir appartient à ceux qui
se lèvent tôt et ça c'est une torture ce
veto une humiliation une humiliation une
humiliation
je crois que je serai une soirée avec
rocco siffredi dans une boîte échangiste
rhin est mort celle des autres bravo
yann moix ali ces accords comme chez
grasset
décidément pas acheter il faut l'acheter
dianne watts 2 km à lorient yann moix
[Musique]
sa bonne amie marie noëlle lienemann
franck dubosc david hallyday voilà donc
il y en a près jubilation vers le ciel
après les cimetières sont des champs de
fleurs après anissa corto vous publiez
votre quatrième roman qui s'appelle
podium alors pour la sortie de l'anis à
corto vous aviez fait passer une annonce
viennent dans la presse avec appelle moi
et mon xp draft en fait appel moix avec
votre numéro de portable alors résultat
beaucoup de lecteurs de têtu le fameux
magazine gay vous ont téléphoné il ya
une fille quand même qui vous a
téléphoné en me disant j'ai envie de toi
est vite et vous avez compris quelques
jours plus tard que c'était trois
copains du figaro en fait que vous avez
fait une sale blague
est-ce que ce soir vous êtes prêts à
recommencer à donner à l'antenne votre
numéro de portable
yann moix 06 62 37 61 60
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un petit
rappelé serge s'il te plaît
06 62 37 61 60
voilà nos deux lignes mon ami je vais
noté alors bien alors on arrive à la
question désormais chaque semaine dans
cette émission il y aura une question
qui s'appelle la question alors cette
semaine j'ai hésité entre la question
trop con pour que je vous la pose moi
même et la question de claire chazal et
finalement j'ai choisi la question de
claire chazal
attention vous êtes prêt yann moix
attention est ce qu'on peut dire yann
moix que podium et le roman de la
rentrée à l'ewi je crois que c'est le
moment de la rentrée
ouais en fait je suis tout beaucoup trop
modeste pour me comparer aux écrivains
français est mort alors si je me compare
aux écrivains français vivant on peut
effectivement dire que c'est le roman la
rentrée et ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que c'est bizarre parce que c'est un
roman sur les saisies coûteront c'est
claude françois alors si bizarre c'est
moi qui parle des yéyés et si les romans
de la rentrée qui sont vieux de 30 ans à
côté mais bien je vous ai préparé vos
formules pour les règles vous allez
faire c'est bien vous avez regardé le
show pendant les vacances
en tous les cas vous êtes sur la liste
du goncourt maintenant le tout c'est d'y
rester le plus longtemps possible
c'est un peu comme un cheval de rodéo
oui c'est comme un jeu un peu télé où il
faut pas tomber
voilà c'est ça vous n'êtes pas très
souriant c'est vrai vous n'êtes jamais
très souriant et j'ai appris en lisant
paris match que quand vous étiez petit
on vous avait mis des bagues sur les
dents vous appelez d'ailleurs la banane
metalik sculpte web un surnom et zip et
halles centrales nucléaires etc
ces plaisanteries vous n'avez plus le
comme vous avez pu le faire mais vous
avez le mas si je souris toujours mais
par les yeux par les oreilles par les
cheveux par les mains mais j'arrive plus
à sourire par la bouche qui a peu
paradoxal
voilà j'essaie de me forcer ça se voit
sonnés les gros bras sont là elles ne
vont pas tout
je dirais mais moi je peux pas moi c'est
pareil comme un animateur télé c'est
même ce qu'il faut faire et regarder
sabatier vous l'avez eu ça aussi voulait
et c'est à peu près tout vous avez vous
avez ça allait les bacs sur les vandales
loquace que oui oui le terrain enfin le
carnival espèce de casque etc les dents
et un jour j'avais ça je dormais avec
une amie ne pas rentrer a dit pat
écoutons hoffman en fait il fait un truc
c'était terrible alors on a passé un
podium yann le pitch de podium c'est
l'histoire d'un sosie de claude françois
effectivement que sa belle bernard
frédéric et puis il a un copain qui
s'appelle jean baptiste cousseau dit
couscous qui est le narrateur lui c'est
un ex sosie de claude françois mais il
est recyclé en sosie de ces jérôme sinon
2d jérôme ce qui vient après lui
viendront torture que le livre est très
très drôle
alors ce bernard frédéric basse et un
sosie dissidents non agréé par le club
officiel lens mais c'est ça ce qu'elle
est c'est officiel est saisie freelance
voilà alors il doit effectivement
refaire tous les concours parce qu'il
veut participer à l'émission d'evelyne
thomas que nous saluons ici c'est mon
choix
voilà un et donc été obligé de retourner
un petit peu à l'école des sosies de
passer des concours
les titres de chaque chapitre sont des
chansons de claude françois
c'est un bel exercice exact il ya même
une chanson qui s'appelle hip hip hip
hourra
oui qu'il a une chanson de gainsbourg
qu'il avait enregistré en 67 et
lorsqu'elle plus drôle c'est les entrées
de chapitres toutes ses phrases que vous
que vous relevez de la bouche des sosies
il y en a un qui dit j'ai enfin c'est
bien à frédéric qui dit j'ai toute la
vie de claude françois devant moi oui
d'ailleurs j'ai voulu qu'elle se livre à
cause de deux phrases comme on dit les
saisies claude françois avec qui j'avais
déjeuné et la phrase qui a tout
déclenché c'est un sosie qui apprennent
pas de m'avoir parlé de claude françois
pendant une heure et demie me dit tu
sais jan je suis beaucoup mieux dans ma
peau depuis que dans celle de claude il
ya un autre un autre déjeuner me parle
pendant une heure et demie et à la fin
du déjeuner me dit cette phrase démente
et là je me suis décidé à écrire le
roman il me dit s'y prête un claude
françois comme les autres c'est pas la
peine
j'avais mon sujet et même si c'est
françois était claude françois dès sa
naissance mois il a fallu que je
travaille comme un malade pour rattraper
mon retard
il y avait vraiment des perles et puis
pendant le concours aussi font donc le
concours vont participer pour devenir un
vrai sosie pour participer à l'émission
d'evelyne thomas et il dit le prof dit
c'est pas parce que vous êtes des sosies
qui faut copier mise en examen que plus
bas que voilà l'un qui disent que je
préfère en moi c'est claude et depuis
j'en ai eu notre fabuleuse qu'on a bien
saisi mais je peux plus l'intégrer dans
le roman et c'est trop les dix ans -
claude françois serait resté claude
françois et nous aidiez à ce moment là
j'ai compris que je tenais non seulement
à un sujet de roman mais un thème
universel finalement thèmes universels
d'autant que aujourd'hui on est dans la
le terrorisme de la célébrité et en même
temps dans la démocratisation de la de
la star et de la célébrité mais c'est ça
c'est vachement intéressant de
comprendre qu'on est dans une époque où
la notoriété précède l'oeuvre et même
parfois la remplace c'est à dire que
avant on faisait une oeuvre une chanson
un livre et on devenait éventuellement
célèbre aujourd'hui on est célèbre
d'abord et on regarde ce qu'ont fait
qu'il faut remplir la notoriété dans la
chose mais on a un vase qui s'appelle la
célébrité on regarde ce qu'on peut
mettre dedans et si ça continue comme ça
c'est les inconnues qui vont devenir
parfaitement célèbre mêmes on dira donc
n'est pas inconnu toi j'espère que m il
y aura dans les boîtes de nuit des vip
very important people se réuniront dans
des carrés à cet effet loin que les gens
qui ne sont pas passés à la télé il y en
aura plus que cinq ou six
plus vous citez souvent l'exemple de
david du loft qui dit moins célèbres
c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu faire
et nombreux à être non c'est à dire que
le fer et le lettres se sont venus
connexes et la célébrité d'anonymat sont
devenus synonymes
je sais par exemple depuis deux ans en
regardant les couvertures de ty télé 7
jours sont des stars en couverture de
sept jours parce que je ne connais pas
et comme sont des anonymes je sais que
c'est des gens connus c'est vrai tout ça
se passe dans un univers très france
d'en bas de shopi shop de bricorama sans
mépris d'ailleurs devant
j'ai pas mépriser l'endroit où j'ai
habité pendant 20 ans c'est à peu près
d'orléans jetterait province très on
travaille bien que sur ce qu'on connaît
après tout faut que mr ne travailler que
sur quelques mètres carrés avec un champ
de maïs une grange et puis un fleuve pas
loin puis ça suffit pour faire un roman
c'est même trop mais c'est vrai que
depuis houellebecq qui a un temps danse
comme ça à regarder la réalité dans les
romans oui je crois que la définition on
peut donner un écrivain c'est quelqu'un
qui nous parle du monde dans lequel on
vit actuellement
si c'est pour faire des livres qui
aurait pu se passer en 1936 c'est pas
tellement intéressant en fait enfin tous
les cas c'est un livre plutôt bien
ficelé une rentrée bien orchestré les
médias se sont fait l'écho qu'elle le
dit c'est le cas de le dire oui tout va
très bien mais mais un problème lequel
vous savez bien car je savais qu'il y
aurait un problème pour le lait il ya
pour l'abus jour un problème oui là il y
en a justement vous mettez les homos ado
oui oui et oui le personnage bien sûr
vous dis que c'est pas moi c'est le
personnage mais ça les gens crédules
sont pas dus et il vous en veulent c'est
vrai que ce personnage très santoni est
ce que s'en prend violemment aux
homosexuels vous avez du tout parce que
les phrases qui ont été relevés par le
magazine têtu ne sont pas des pires non
non il y en a bien pire en fait je pars
du principe que je n'ai pas aimé les
homosexuels et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est pour moi les homosexuels
n'existe pas exactement comme les
hétérosexuels n'existe pas je considère
qu'il a une sexualité par personne que
la communauté homosexuelle c'est quelque
chose qui m'échappe comme si par exemple
dans une communauté des mecs à lunettes
blond avec des doubles foyer qui mettent
des baskets adidas
je trouve que pourquoi non mais c'est
vrai c'est très étrange ce serait drôle
l'armée
el hadj est en dise n'est ça je trouve
que la sexualité quelque chose tellement
individuel que je pense que parfois il
ya moins de différences entre un
hétérosexuel et un homosexuel qu'entre
deux homosexuels est donc tout
simplement il ya que les individus qui
m'intéresse et comme il ya une sexualité
par individu j'ai pas à dire j'aime les
homosexuels cette phrase ne fait pas
sens chez moi exactement comme la phrase
j'aime ou j'aime pas les hétérosexuels
fait pas sens où les bisexuels et dans
la rome antique on faisait même pas ces
distinctions il n'y avait que la
sexualité quelque chose d'individuel
vous êtes cuir verni cuir sans le savoir
elle a du beau temps mais il ya il ya
quand même des phrases cléry vous dites
je ne suis pas homosexuel j'ai pas un
cancer du slip comme classe naomi je
recule jeunes paj thierry le luron pas
georges mesnager dire ça dans les romans
français personnages à peine le sida et
un cancer du slip parce qu'il parle de
manière très imagée et que je me suis
amusé en fait et il trouver un langage
neuf langues pour ce personnage dans les
romans burlesque
en fait on fait souvent ça et pour
trouver ce langage j'ai croisé le roman
de renart et les interviews de jean
claude van damme et ça donne ça on le
connaît bien ici jean claude van damme
comme un musée
non non plus
vous avez face à vous les pédales on
peux vraiment pas vous sentir déjà que
dans les hôpitaux on poireaute des
plombes à cause de vos filles ont
infecté
c'est beaucoup mais attendez je précise
quand même que c'est mon personnage qui
parle et gc j'ai essayé de faire un
personnage antipathique
non je crois j'y suis arrivé là et le
mec le mec est radin dire qu'il va il
passe sa vie dans les restaurants à
volonté par exemple 25 fois une demande
de des suppléments viande jusqu'à temps
qu'ils meurent actuellement tout ce qui
est gratuit il est preneur nous et puis
en même temps je voulais rendre encore
plus antipathique donc en plus ils
homophobes on considère que l'homophobie
la radinerie sont parmi les défauts les
pires que puisse avoir un être humain
voilà j'en ai fait un personnage ou
moins dans tous les cas c'est un roman
très drôle très picaresque un peu
amphigourique de temps en temps oui non
c'est le deuxième problème de la soirée
non non ça c'est un problème pour moi le
pas pour le bouquin on sait très bien
que j'espère est ce qui est des sosies
de johnny hallyday beaucoup non oui je
connais ainsi johnny hallyday qui m'a
dit une phrase inoubliable il m'a dit je
suis bien content que johnny se soit
stabilisée senti mentalement parce que
j'arrive plus à suivre
alors j'ai cherché j'ai trouvé des
photos d'un sosie de david mais
franchement je n'ai pas invité ce soir
parce que il est beaucoup moins bon vous
vous le connaissez votre saisie non non
pas du tout non parce que michel sardou
il connaît son sosie ya eu plein de
problèmes avec son sosie dénommé quart
du serge cardu ouais ok en tôle avant
une antenne le scoop vous connaissez pas
le vôtre de la prochaine fois je
l'inviterai avec pc inpact de m'avoir
invité
bosc et je pense que franck dubosc
viendra dans une autre émission pour
parler du boulot franck dubosc
en tous les cas vous montrer une
érudition extraordinaire sur claude
françois vous avez lu beaucoup tous les
podiums qui était son journal et le
titre de votre itunes et mademoiselle
âge tendre salut les copains meilleur
pour ce livre j'ai lu la bible
intégralement ce que j'avais mais
j'avais fait don quichotte et tous les
numéros deux podiums et tous les livres
que j'ai trouvé sur peau de françois
ouais c'est ça un mixage de tout ça puis
ça donne un livre en fait oui parce
qu'on apprend beaucoup de choses sur
claude françois en même temps je dirais
est d'abord vous tordez le cou à cette
rumeur sur la mort de claude françois on
dit toujours la star a été électrocuté
par un godemiché dans son bain un
vibromasseur ni un vibrant basse alors
j'ai enquêté effectivement dans ce livre
il ya la description de la mort de
claude françois seconde par seconde et
un jour je me suis dit bon 7 tests
viraux minceur qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir faire pour lui la guillotine est
et j'ai une idée toute bête chez les
dames rue saint denis dans un sex-shop
et sans parler de peau de françois je
suis arrivé et j'ai dit un petit voilà
je voudrais offrir un vibromasseur à ma
copine mais j'ai peur qu'ils aient des
problèmes parce que puisque les
s'électrocuter autres ils vivent pas du
tout les défenseurs ça marche pas sur
secteur ça marche à piles
versailles est une légende s'évapore en
quelques secondes balles à ce simple que
ça
alors il est mort comment claude
françois c'est un obsessionnel un
maniaque un dingue et il ne pouvait pas
supporter par exemple que sur son bureau
le crayon de papier soit pas parallèles
à l'angle du bureau et c'était toujours
comme ça et donc kevin ampoules qu'il
narguait depuis des semaines et un jour
il s'est dit bon c'est elle ou moi ça
peut plus durer soit elle fait un effort
elle se rectifie d'elle-même soit je
vais être obligée de me lever et de
faire moi même et ça il supportait pas
les rapports de comme il avait les pieds
dans l'eau il a appris le courant voilà
alors il s'est levé et il a reçu la
lumière puisqu'un livre christie qui ont
une peau plus c'est vrai
il est sur moi
ouais si julie depardieu et yann moix
[Musique]
julie depardieu yann moix bonsoir à tous
les deux c'est ici évidemment pour
podium inutile de le cacher plus
longtemps
film de yann moix avec julie depardieu
jean paul rouve et benoît poelvoorde
le pitch or là vous allez le faire ce
que vous avez fait le bouquin est le
fils ce que je peux pas le faire le
pitch si l'histoire d'un sosie de claude
françois qui a raccroché
ouais et un de ses meilleurs amis venant
voir une grande cérémonie des saisies
organisé par evelyne thomas le pousse à
recommencer à retomber dans son vice qui
claude françois au grand dam de sa femme
interprétée par juillet par lieu voilà
et son métier c'est claude françois mais
là le héros il est vraiment dépendant
lui aussi c'est un film sur la
dépendance a ordonné de compris c'est un
film sur la dépendance le héros son vice
c'est claude françois isaac tombe dans
l'alcool y un instant dans la drogue qui
tombe dans le sexe donc qui tombe dans
le jeu lui tombe dans claude france la
religion claude françois la religion
cloclo ouais c'est ça si l'on veut dire
lent et il est adepte de cette religion
et voilà comme ça
voilà c'est exactement ça on ne change
pas de sujet en fait je trouve que c'est
peut-être un petit peu moins dangereux
conceptual continuity voilà oui alors
d'abord vous avez eu l'idée d'un film
vous allez voir poelvoorde en échange de
faire un film là-dessus vous a dit oui
au fait t'es gentil j'ai fait un roman
vous êtes revenu voir sa durée 5 ans
vous avez été d'un courage exemple je me
suis arrangée pour que poelvoorde joue
dans mon livre c'est à dire que je vais
injecter j'ai pu le voir disait mon
roman
avec sa verve sa scansion j'ai foutu du
pouvoir dans le bouquin et un jour je
lui dis tiens lis à a- et mi temps mais
c'est moi ça ouais et donc du coup il
avait envie de faire le film
s'ils avaient dit non vous auriez pape
et le final on serait rentré chez moi
continuer à écrire des livres vraiment
faire de toute façon à nice à corto
c'était pas mal non plus et souvent me
dit est ce que c'est comment de faire un
film et je réponds je ne sais pas faire
un film moi je ne sais faire que un film
avec benoît poelvoorde
ouais j'en fais un meilleur laura julie
depardieu dans un pool de vorey
obsessionnel et alors vous avez dit
aussi personne d'autre ne peut le
réaliser à ma place c'est quand même
gonflé parce qu'elle vous enfilez plein
de thunes pour faire ce film alors vous
aviez jamais fait de film avant tout
qu'ils voulaient me fille est encore
plus et une pour ne pas le faire
donc maintenant je voulais pas céder
parce que on n'est jamais mieux trahi
par soi même même travers moi même car
je ne suis pas très fiable y compris
vers moi mais c'est difficile le cadre
l'image comme ça c'est des choses je
faisais la bd avant d'écrire des
bouquins ça m'a vachement aider en fait
ouais
et puis après j'ai regardé plein de
films non pour un premier film on peut
dire c'est je parle visu
elle ment assez réussie quand même parce
que c'est 50 boulot j'ai commencé ce
truc que j'avais 29 ans là j'aurai
bientôt 36 kw c'est dur alors quant à
julie depardieu vous êtes rencontrés
dans un bar en 1996 tous les deux et
vous a dit je suis sûr qu on travaillera
ensemble
j'ai rigolé je savais pas qu'elle était
j depardieu fine blonde que je draguais
aller non en fait moi j'étais avec une
copine qui était brune qui a l'air de
plaire aussi la télé donc la vie et non
on était toutes les deux et me dis-je un
court métrage là avec un hamster un truc
très hystérique j'ai bien compris
j'avais dit ware écoute moi je ne suis
pas triste donc ça tombe bien donc il
drague en disant qu'il fait des cours
ouais mystère therrien hamster c'est un
peu cet oral oui et deux ans plus tard
vous l'avez fait ouais mais il a de la
suite dans les idées de garçons est
assez ça fait deux fois de suite là
alors vous avez dit vous en tous les cas
dans tous les films que je ferais julie
oui c'est la meilleure actrice de sa
génération assez devenir actrice sa
génération il est incroyable parce que
quand on arrive sur un tournage la chose
la moins importante pour elle de la
journée c'est le moment où on tourne
ouais ouais nan mais apparemment
apparemment apparemment mais sa façon de
se concentrer c'est de n'avoir rien à
[ __ ] elle se fout d'être là bas quand
on regarde le truc quand on est quand on
regarde sur plateau d'hymes qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc mais ça va jamais
marché et quand on voit les rushs ça
marche on voit pas pourquoi c'est assez
étonnant on vous dit julie moi j'ai pas
de propositions à faire sur un plateau
alors que tous les acteurs font des
propositions au real j'ai pas
d'imagination j'ai pas d'idée
c'est vrai on nous demande je fais ce
que je peux et quand on me dit non ça va
pas alors effectivement je commence à me
me remuer un peu là où mais maintenant
je suis pas quelqu'un qui propose
beaucoup je propose moi c'est je trouve
que c'est déjà c'est déjà ça vous avez
un nom mais je sais vous avez ce côté là
c'est dire comme vous étiez petit à
l'école met à raconter ça une fois quand
elle avait une copine protestante était
protestante ou copines jiva était juive
une que connaissait à zellik un peu oui
vous dites j'ai aucune admiration pour
les gens qui réussissent je trouve au
contraire beaucoup plus émouvant ce
qu'ils ratent ouais ouais j'aime bien
les gens qui réussissent mais ça nous
donne ça ça ne me fait rien la réussite
est la forme la plus subtile de l'échec
ouais ou la deuxième carte fille à noter
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont copains
si tu veux oui aux états unis je me fous
de plaire l'enjeu c'est pas trop me
détester oui enfin c'est pas plaire au
plus grand nombre tout ouais ouais c'est
plaire à une petite poignée à qui on a
envie de plaire à la rue alors voulais
pas spécialement être une star a volé
devant mon ambition c'est ça va très
bien mais mon ambition c'est d'avoir des
poules
oui mon projet 2004 celle annoncée avait
24 le poulailler et la volaille et j'en
aurai 3 je sais déjà les prénoms je sais
tout elles seront rousse et non c'est
mon projet voilà c'est un dribble pas
d'enfant voulait pas d'enfant papale à
la wii après peut-être mais vous vous
dites que vous trouver ridicule et les
les actrices qui disent dans paris match
ou dans gala depuis que j'ai un enfant
je vis un rêve mais j'essaierai
franchement si ça m'arrive je suis fait
un pari donc c'est un pari idiot si
vraiment si je le dis
là je me fais un gros nuage je ne veux
pas le dire ça parce que c'est une
évidence on le sait à quoi bon le dire
et je trouve ça ridicule de moi en tout
cas je ne dirais pas même si c'est vrai
je pars dans paris match en tout cas
voilà non je ne dirais pas non
même si même si c'est vrai mais ça
m'arrache la gueule je ne dirai jamais
alors contrairement à votre père et à
votre frère vous dit vraiment vous
défier très très peu la chronique
vous êtes d'une calme études absolument
exemplaire non mais c'est surtout que
non j'ai rien à dire enfin pas au plus
grand nombre tout cas on va essayer
quand même en affaires est intervenu
quand on s'appelle depardieu
quand on s'appelle depardieu escompte
cdpa de chaque fois qu'on ne tombe de
vélo
non moi si je faisais une pub je serais
pour le ménage le seul truc auquel je
croise et les produits ménagers je
pensais quand on s'appelle depardieu est
ce qu'on tient bien l'alcool
ouais ouais cette famille ouais parce
qu'on fait son vin soi même est ce que
quand on s'appelle depardieu on investit
son argent un peu n'importe comment non
quand on en a pas est-ce qu'on a plus
facilement des tableaux restaurant non
parce qu'on dit pas son nom
on a plus facilement des restaurants
peut-être est-ce qu'on a forcément un
drôle de rire quand on s'appelle
depardieu non regardez le mien est très
correct est ce que quand on s'appelle de
pardies on a parfois envie de porter un
autre nom oh oui oui mais là c'est un
peu tard maintenant j'aurais dû j'aurais
dû le faire à 12 ans comme on m'avait
proposé un qui avait proposé ce même mon
père voulait que t'appelles comment on
ne sait pas elle n'avait pas proposé
mais il avait dira je vois que ça te les
dunes de par bf
non
dacca yann moix hommes
son design tu connais tout le monde
presque à par mademoiselle mademoiselle
david qui joue dans le film yvan attal
ils se marièrent et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants qui est un gros succès c'est
même le seul succès du cinéma français
cet été il faut bien dire les choses
d'un filigrane et voilà tu connais
emmanuelle seigner oui bonsoir a relaté
un peu sous le charme quand même oui
vous savez longtemps c'est pas un scoop
agathe de la trentaine que je découvre
je découvre la fontaine pour à l'auteur
bravo anciennement tandy moi tu as vu
l'intérêt d'agathe oui j'ai vu à vernon
c'était émouvant
les femmes blessées sont plus belles que
les femmes heureuses et voilà et voilà
tensions et les metteurs en scène aussi
là
qui a fait un film s'appelle podium ah
c'est toi
ouais c'est pas dieu je ne savais pas du
tout que c'était de jean paul rouve
julie depardieu et ça a fait 3,6
millions d'entrées c'est bien c'est
josiane à un énorme apport il ya un dvd
qui sort avec 35 minutes en plus je les
ai vus alors il ya des trucs formidables
par exemple à sienne il ya tous les
sosies d'elvis qui qui déjeunent entre
eux pourquoi ça peut être gardé dans le
film ça parce qu'on a ça cassait le
rythme il ya un mois j'ai je pense qu'au
montage il faut être sans pitié il faut
pas trop s'écouter et adam
donc tout ce qui déborde je sais pas ce
qu'on veut en suivant mais je pense que
un film une comédie d'une heure trente
s'est bien qu'elle mathieu a été déjà
mais je crois qu'il belle vista des
choses qui est incroyable c'est dingue
alors aujourd'hui il ya deux mois que
vous travaillez à l'adaptation
d'amicalement vôtre vous avez un rôle
pour agathe de la fontaine tout va
s'arranger
merci mais oui je te dis je vais me
rattraper je suis à voir tu vas voir
bien ragga tu n'es pas contente de son
interview aux folies d'hier n'ont pas du
tout avoir un ouais les colères reprise
ample pour une conne pourtant pour te
prendre pour une conne faux
d'imagination wifi d'accord mais il en a
pas eu sur ce coup là non non comment je
peux faire pour me rattraper
mais je vais voir bella déjà non c'est
pas mal à l'église ou non pas encore
les bisous c'est après justement va y
venir aux bisous vous publié il ya deux
mois que c'est grâce et un livre qui
s'appelle par tous à 100 e
sans eux et dans la typo moi que ça
c'est à dire que maintenant il ya c'est
la typo deux podiums voyez inscriptions
il ya une typo yann moix là sinon quand
vous sortez un bouquin de poésie par
exemple transfusion c'est encore la même
type
vous aurez remarqué que je restais un
peu bloqué dans la typographie flunch
1976 c'est vrai c'est mon truc
alors le titre partout sans eux parce
que vous dites que finalement partout
avec eux ça fait un peu années 70 ça
fait losier ça fait pompidou je trouve
que nous partout c'est un mot un peu
vieillot un peu ringard tout de suite
compris de tous ces morts quand une
longue jusqu à il ya 20 mois d'une
adrien cet été j'étais en vacances à
rome et j'envoie un texto à laurent
baffie qui je suis à rome je t'embrasse
moins de trente secondes plus tard je
reçois un texto de baffie qui je suis à
mykonos je t'encule
certaines bonnes vacances et un mot
extrêmement désolés et le seul fait don
weiss à l'aérodynamisme est le dernier
cet argent sale islami je sais mais
comme naguib mahfouz l'écrivain égyptien
voilà deux non plus bah oui c'est
l'islam is un peu alors le pitch bien il
est très fort et très simple le mariage
c'est l'enfer passer à table mohammed
atta est devenu intégristes musulmans
après avoir pris un râteau avec une
dénommée pas mais la witch ailleurs
quand il était étudiant à l'université
du caire en 1989 1990 je me dis que les
grands chefs-d'oeuvre de la littérature
sont peut-être dû à une femme qui nous
avaient conduits et que les grande
apocalypse sont aussi peut-être dû à une
douleur originel qui n'a pas été très
bien soigné alors la thèse du livre
c'est de l'inventer effectivement une
pamela wilshire qui a éconduit mohammed
atta qui avait dit je ne veux pas de toi
alors le mec il écrivait des lettres et
ses seins et un jour lui dit t'inquiète
pas un jour je vais te préparer quelque
chose exactement comme diderot le
faisait dans un correspondant c'est que
ce fût volant comme mitterrand a écrit à
catherine langeais pendant 50 ans dans
je t'aime je t'aime il est devenu
président la république
sans doute parce que catherine langeais
n'a pas voulu lui et là ma thèse est qui
et qui perd très personnel et aussi
parce qu'un romancier doit écrire des
choses que des journalistes n'écrivent
pas parce qu'elle correspond à une
parcelle de réalité qui est un peu
oubliée écarté c'est que mohammed atta
lily un jour le 10 septembre il appelle
y écoute je vais avoir ma revanche
demain c'est mon septembre ton quoi 11
septembre
parce que quand on prend le 8 octobre
1982 le 11 septembre 2001 il existait
déjà potentiellement n'était pas la date
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
là maintenant il ya un trade marks c'est
en septembre tmc devenu comme nike ou
adidas l'on s'est tant que c'est un marc
griffe est alors la thèse du truc c'est
que mohammed atta ali ben voilà demain
je passe à la télé
regarde moi tu vas avoir de mes
nouvelles n'a pas voulu de moi voilà ma
revanche
alors évidemment c'est une espèce
d'orchestration extrêmement subjective
de
d'un point de vue extrêmement farfelu
extrêmement névrotique parce que moi je
suis un grand grand grand brûlés de
l'amour et même si après j'ai eu plus de
succès que les femmes je ne suis jamais
parvenu à complètement digéré les 2/3
râteau que j'ai subie quand j'entends 9
22 ans quoi et à partir de ça j'essaie
de construire modestement une oeuvre
littéraire et voilà et mohamed atta
c'est votre frère je sais mon frère de
sang je pense que pendant que moi je me
branle et lui prier il est né en 1968
tous les deux si j'étais né au caire
fragile comme je le suis sorti
mentalement il n'est pas impossible que
je me sois inventé un islam perso un
islam portable un islam très très très
personnelle et que peut-être que
j'aurais moi aussi verser dans al qaïda
alors là on rentre dans une alternance
entre deux types de chapitre des
chapitres sur mohammed atta et et permet
la witch ailleurs et puis des chapitres
qui se passe dans une boîte de partouzes
qui s'appelle le recto verso
je comprends pas pourquoi j'avais pris
le titre d'une émission de paul amar jeu
c'est vrai le pauvre avec le mal qui se
donne à l'est c'est vrai il est très
vexé voulais pas non non non ils vous
envoient énormément de boîtes de
préservatifs pour m'excuser non j'ai pas
pensé du tout honnêtement les
descriptions de boîte à partouze
absolument génial notamment j'ai aimé
les les [ __ ] célinienne et les
lessiveuses proustienne c'est quoi la
différenciant c'est que j'ai remarqué
que quand je me faisais sucer il y avait
j'ai remarqué c'est très personnel qui
avait des filles qui passé énormément de
temps à faire des allers venues à faire
semblant de faire j'accuse et puis en
fait elles le font pas et c'est ça prend
un temps fou ça s'étire ça revient ça
revient
sarah thuram et sarah tueur et puis il
ya les sedin yen qui s'usent par un coût
exact sera un point d'exclamation non
pas par grande fierté et le gland à
pouss mal hein
par exemple la sucent célinienne ne
viendrait jamais à l'idée de lécher les
couilles c'est vrai alors que la piste
hier c'est vrai michel oui je suis
plutôt ces lignes elle nous proustien
des je fais ce que je veux ouais
décideurs tv la juxtaposition peut
paraître gratuite j'ai en fait deux
choses d'abord j'ai l'impression qu'une
démocratisation l'échangisme aujourd'hui
et que le sexe est devenu quelque chose
de grande consommation
et parce que je décris ça d'une manière
vraiment très consommatrice de vraiment
de d'énergie de consommation et de
frénésie sexuelle sans le moindre
sentiment est ce que j'ai remarqué en
boîte échangiste j'y suis allée dix fois
la dernière fois c'était d'ailleurs la
veille à la veille du 11 septembre 2001
j'ai pas vu beaucoup de bof j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de bourrins j'ai vraiment vu
des blessés de l'amour un des types qui
ne supporte plus les quelques minutes
nécessaires et obligatoires qui nous
oblige à les dire à une femme tu me
plaît j'ai envie de toi on et moi je
suis un handicapé de ça je suis
incapable de regagner fille ya rien de
plus violents sur terre que d'aller dire
une fille tu me plais moi je sais pas
faire ça alors évidemment les boîtes
échangistes c'est quelque chose où cette
cette douleur là est complètement abolie
on a un accès direct aux organismes
humains ce que je trouve absolument
génial
oui c'est le lapin alors le lapin c'est
pages 160 et 163 ce type était
absolument fascinant je l'avais baptisé
le lapin un peu trivialement j'avoue
mais nick est comme un malade sans
jamais faire de pause les seuls pause
qu'il s'autorisait c'était pour changer
de préservatifs parce qu en limant la
même fille pendant près de deux heures
wulff aller de temps en temps faire
attention à ce que la capote ne brûle
pas avec les frottements incessant de la
[ __ ] contre la paroi vaginal ou anal pas
loin de lui dans ses parages ça sentait
vraiment comme une odeur de caoutchouc
brûlé comme quand on conduisait quelques
kilomètres en ayant oublié de débloquer
le frein à main
mais lui le lapin il ne freinait pas il
ne freinaient jamais il attaque et il se
saccadé il donnait ses petits coups de
reins frénétique presque fou avec les
yeux ronds presque impassible d'un robot
et fracassé les côtes le cul les cuisses
les reins de tout ce qui lui passait
sous la verge des petites et des rondes
des intellectuels et des vieilles des
rousses et des blacks des blacks rousse
des sublimes [ __ ] et des moches
relativement mal à l'aise des bombes et
des très peu sexy des vicieuse et des
scolaires des vendeuses de parfums et
des philosophes
j'avais remarqué une chose étrange chez
lui il notait jamais ses chaussettes
pour baiser
il était complètement à poil sauf les
chaussettes
cela lui conférer une allure burlesque
extrêmement peu érotique mais les femmes
s'en fiche et ça leur semble et un
honneur de passer sous le laminage le
burinage de sa cage l'usinage le
bizutage de pilonnages le pilotage de
cela par la voilà
ou alors je moi j'ai vu le mec [ __ ]
mais alors il à poil 117 et je me suis
demandé ce qu'il y avait dedans alors il
y avait une espèce de petit rectangle
dans les chaussettes je crois que c'est
sa carte bleue mais dans les boîtes
échangistes ya pas de carte bleue on
laisse tout un vestiaire en liquide
et en fait le mec il avait des réserves
de préservatifs dans les chaussettes
pour parler c'est un choix c'est ça
alors il ya plein de notation très très
juste sur l'amour par exemple les gens
qui gicle et les faits cependant la
levrette vous dit que c'est une question
d'instinct et finalement ça plaît c'est
très étrange
donc moi j'étais là dedans et puis au
début un peu perdu ces il faut bien le
comprendre c'est quand même un univers
auquel on s'habitue vite mais les
premières minutes sont quand même assez
intimidante et
il espère de complicité qui se nouent
immédiatement et je vois un type qui me
regarde il fait un clin d'oeil il me dit
le vrai de claquer il commence à fait
c'est une nana
j'attends du vocabulaire le vrai de
claquer chef de cabinet comme le truc
qui m'a le plus somatisé parce que je me
suis ramassé une fois un râteau dans une
boîte échangiste faut le faire parce que
tous sommes en décembre est censé
pouvoir avoir accès c'est bien à
n'importe quel organisme biologique
humain j'arrive tout timide penaud
tabitha romantique hexa cores et des
lauriers vignes fille qui était en train
de se refaire une levrette par un mec
pendant sa vie ou pas donc la caisse
elle la classique et elle était en train
de sucer un autre j'arrive tout bêtement
promis et imaginez monsieur hulot arrive
et je commence à mettre ma main sur son
sein gauche
hélas elle enlève le sexe qu'il avait
dans la bouche elle nous regarde dit non
ça va pas être possible es sûr mais
c'est ça qui est bon
bon gars sait puisqu'on des râteaux
alors que c'est un échange où ils
atteindront un échange de l'est après ça
il me donner du plaisir
il a même pas le droit de donner du
plaisir ensuite il a une panne ce qui
quand même dans une boîte échangiste est
quand même très emmerdant et à la fin
quand il touche au but
il a une et jacques précoce quoi oui
c'est un monde qui à l'ère communiste
comme ça parce qu'on a l'impression que
tout le monde peut s'échanger que tout
le monde dans un grand bain démocratique
et des changes absolument égalitaire
c'est faux c'est ultra libérale une
boîte échangiste c'est à dire que dans
la société actuelle c'est peut-être le
plus beau ou le plus riche ou le celui
qui a le plus de succès qui arrive à
coucher que les filles là bas c'est
quand même c'est horrible à dire mais
c'est le sait celui qui a la meilleure
érection quoi et c'est alors c'est en
quelques secondes que ça se passe les
signe tout de suite tac
donc il ya quand même de l'ultralibéral
si une vraie concurrence c'est un monde
quand même assez effrayant et alors le
parallèle venir qui les rapports entre
entre mohammed atta le personnage
inventé les boîtes échangistes s'amène
en plus la thèse c'est que alors jamais
mais il y a quand même une infime partie
des islamistes qui sont persuadés ils
vont avoir accès au sexe une fois le
arriver au paradis d'arrêt et donc je
compare si vous voulez quelques
deviennent des grands romantiques
occidentaux ils vont baiser dans les
boîtes échangistes et les grands
romantiques islamistes leur accès au
sexe dans une autre boîte échangiste
géantes qui est le paradis des
terroristes paradis des terroristes
voilà il se met des bandelettes sur le
sexe pour le besoin que
à jérusalem où l'eau quand on trouve des
kamikazes ils ont des couches-culottes
comme les enfants pour préserver les
parties génitales et mohamed atta dans
son testament explique que personne n'a
le droit d'y toucher les parties vitales
qu'aucune femme enceinte n'a le droit
d'approcher son corps parce que la
première chose qu'il veut constater une
fois au paradis c'est le bon
fonctionnement de ces grenades
voilà alors le héros est très très fleur
bleue va très romantique et et
finalement vous raconter qu'un jour vous
avez découvert que ça servait à rien
d'envoyer des lettres de 50 pages etc
il suffisait de dire aux femmes tu me
plaît je te veux que ça marchait j'ai
remarqué à titre extrêmement personnelle
que lorsque j'écrivais des lettres de
150 pages en alexandrins aux filles
elles se foutait de ma gueule
et quand j'allais voir gentiment quand
j'allais les voir gentiment pour leur
dire tu me plais énormément j'ai envie
de toi
en général je parvenais à rencontrer à
les revoir et à leur faire l'amour quand
michel tu as envie de faire le livre oui
oui l'islam
bien sûr j'ai dans le lit moi je te vois
ça me paraît toujours incroyable de
partir dans des trucs comme ça que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un côté un peu de
parler de cul c'est comme disait papa le
cul fait vendre et ça se passe
mais non c'est pas du tout est ce que
c'est le vrai sujet d'accord mais c'est
l'essence de ces lignes que je trouve
général un média nancy qui est la
culture et la religion ont créé une
femme entièrement théorique mais page 22
non non non c'est un truc sur ben laden
qui est très bien écrit page 22 le
deuxième paragraphe et des reptiles de
jan kounen
ce qui frappait surtout chez oussama ben
laden quand on le voyait sur ces
fameuses vidéos
c'était qu'il n'y avait chez lui
strictement rien d'antipathie qu il ne
dominait pas le monde d'une domination
aigre et raide comme un pouvoir mais
avec un sourire calme une grande douceur
il était symétriquement à l'opposé de
l'idée qu'on se fait généralement d'un
tyran alors que les maîtres du monde qui
l'avait précédé avaient tous vécu dans
la terreur du couteau de l'assassin ou
du traître et avait régné dans la
paranoïa propre aux usurpateurs oussama
sûr de sa légitimité avait l'air serein
enfantin loyal d'un bon droit bien
authentique bien dynastique
un débonnaire une sorte de roi dagobert
des mille et une nuits sa domination lui
semblait couler de source
et bon enfant est d'autant plus
redoutable pour vous pour moi pour nous
tous d'autant plus redoutable qu'elle
n'était pas seulement maîtresse du monde
mais maîtresse d'elle-même
il est pas il n'est pas agressif ben
laden dans les vidéos non il a inventé
des vidéos non dans les vidéos ah oui
quand on le voit des garçons très posé
il est garant est illégal il est très
bon il s'est adapté ni je ne sais pas
l'apologie de ben laden
jeudi qu' il dégage mais ses qualités
orientale qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir les mêmes chez hitler on n'a jamais
eu huit l'air serein il est entendu
hurler les gens lorsque je serai dans la
paranoïa ou parce qu'il est conscient
que d'une certaine manière il a gagné en
tout cas il en est persuadé
alors que je pense que dans le nazisme
par exemple qui fait toujours la peur
d'avoir déjà perdu alors c'est tellement
énorme votre bouquin qu'un moyen
journalistes qui rentre dans le bouquin
et qui dit mettez apparente dégradé
kadri comme ça y'a un truc qui peut
paraître scandaleux mais c'est pour ça
que je prends des gants pour le dire que
je fais intervenir un journaliste qui
sauve c'est la chose suivante l'on s'est
tant on est tous d'accord que c'était
quelque chose de terrible d'horribles
immonde ignoble indescriptible mais
voilà la petite subtilité
pour nous c'était inimaginable en
septembre vous avez bien d'accord ne
peux pas l'imaginer mais si on se place
du point de vue des terroristes pour eux
c'est bien plus difficile de réussir ce
truc qu'ils ont imaginé passer de la
théorie de ce truc là à la pratique de
ce truc là c'est bien plus difficile que
d'avoir à l'imaginer c'est ça que je dis
s'il l'avait raté ça aurait été un
râteau de plus s'il avait raté ça on se
serait alors ils ont été un peu large
parce qu'ils ont pris deux tours il y
avait donc une tour de rattrapage des
filets c'est une preuve de grandes lâche
un don vous engueuler avec ce
journaliste est alors bon passage je
parlais de péguy qui s'est pris un
râteau avec blanche raphaël douai lbeq
vite que houellebecq est un con hein je
pense que houellebecq est un con mais
j'ai l'assument
ouais je
je dis tranquillement je pense que on ne
peut pas critiquer une religion sans
avoir été l'inspecter l'étudier la
regarde et il a eu des jugements
définitifs sur l'islam sur le coran
alors ce que je pense qu'il avait
absolument une méconnaissance totale la
religion ça passe par le respect quelle
que soit la religion et le moindre la
moindre des choses c'est d'aller lire au
moins les textes quoi et on peut pas
dire que l'islam c'est la merde tout ça
débile il y en a un autre qui trouve pas
grâce à vos yeux c'est ariel wizman
parce qu'il vous a dit un jour que
c'était les beaufs calé dans les boîtes
de tous j'ai rien dit j'ai vraiment rien
que dans le rugby man qui est plutôt un
petit bien le problème et sciences et
qu'il a défendu la thèse que les boîtes
échangistes et héros c'était pour les
beaufs et que les boîtes homo échangiste
donc les backrooms c'était pour les
intellectuels
je pense qu'au bout d'un moment la
révise man devrait choisir entre michel
foucault et jean pierre foucault mais
pas mélanger systématiquement les deux
mois la niche elle toi tu l'aiment
beaucoup il ya je le trouve très très
brillant et oui on peut un peu à être
étonné des du du pij de son bouquin ce
parallèle est très très déconcertant
entre l'islam et les boîtes de cul mais
c'est merveilleusement bien tc aux
illustrations michel en fait non mais
j'ai bien compris ce que moi j'étais un
long temps un grand frustré sentimentale
et sexuelle et ça m'a marqué à vie quoi
j'ai passé dix ans de misère
sentimentale et sexuelle mais c'est
formidable que tu arrives à t'exprimer
tu vois à l'heure où tout le monde tout
ce que ça t'a apporté à cit avait comme
un all in
[Rires]
vous avez envie de vivre bien pas envie
j'adore son fils mais j'ai pas envie de
lire le livre
ouais vous attendez qu'il en fasse un
film non ça vous dit pas ça te dis toi
moi j'ai envie d'aller dans une boîte à
partouze avec le 12 ans qu'elle y est
vrai que mercier ou les jarretelles et
je pense et de son beau vous avez levé
ou c'est marrant ça peut vous donner des
idées en plus non sur l'islam ne vous
gène moix donc ça s'appelle par tous est
édité chez chez grasset est-ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une interview portrait
sexuelle haye si vous étiez une position
la position du tireur couché un
accessoire une femme un tue l'amour
un homme est aphrodisiaque deux femmes
une musique pour faire l'amour
je vous interdis un cri [ __ ] si vous
étiez une pam
une panne de coeur si vous étiez une
perversion un goncourt de bits
un film porno podium un fantasme un
fantasme
attendez laissez moi réfléchir
je passe je sais pas si vous étiez
quelque chose qui fait mal
un fils ce king de mike tyson
si vous étiez une boîte à partouze ma
chambre
si vous étiez une phrase à la con qu'on
dit avant l'amour tu as lu le dernier
livre de jacques attali
si vous étiez une phrase à la con qu'on
dit après l'amour surtout tu le répètes
à personne si vous étiez une tâche
moi si vous étiez un truc qui se fait à
plusieurs un livre de paul loup sulitzer
et c'est grâce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]